well las vegas does continue to grow and
now another project in the works venue
development company oakview group
announcing a 20 thousand seat arena
along with a hotel and casino just south
of the strip at blue diamond and las
vegas boulevard and we have team
coverage on this tonight joe moeller
with plans for that property christian
casares with other projects currently
underway first we said it's joe
this three billion dollar project is not
only big for las vegas but the entire
valley now that developer wants to put
that hotel the casino and the arena
right here at this lot now this would
mean more entertainment here in las
vegas and even possibly more sporting
events something that people are
welcoming
entertainment business is not getting
any smaller yet another massive project
for las vegas wednesday the oakview
group announced plans to build a hotel
casino and 20 thousand seat arena at
blue diamond and las vegas boulevard
there's a need for a new arena for the
most spectacular arena in the world this
is las vegas i think everybody has seen
what what they've done over time mark
bedan is the former president for the
las vegas raiders he is the consultant
for the project renderings of the
privately funded project are still in
the works he says the venue development
company's track record is proof this can
get done they just opened seattle they
just opened the arena in belmont ubs
arena and climate pledge arena
after the golden knights made las vegas
home the raiders soon followed many
wonder what is next an mlb or nba team i
guess the best thing to say is the
building will be ready if they want to
come but
we're not building it with the
expectation and then that would
hopefully be an opportunity to pursue
the nba when they're ready the
announcement is welcoming news for those
in the industry our team is extremely
excited about all the opportunities that
are showing up at our doorstep ingrid
and alfonso rosa are from elf
entertainment they hire labor workers
for stage events we've been hit more
than any other industry they say this is
good news since the pandemic from the
nfl draft to the super bowl they say
more events and venues in las vegas
means more business for our industry
we're just super excited about a new
venue new challenges
back out here live vidane says there is
no set start date but they expect to
break ground in 2023 and there's no
timeline for this project but
considering he says how fast the legion
stadium went up he expects this project
to be pretty quick as well reporting
live joe mulder live local now